So now that we've defined out type, we want to create some objects of that type.
And the way to that is to use the class name followed by a parameter list. This
could be empty, but you still need the parens. This is just like when we call a
function. So, for the restaurant type, we don't need any parameters. So, we'll
create a restaurant object, just like this. This is just like any other object
in Python, we can assign it to a variable. If we're doing this outside the
restaurant module, we need to import. So, what we'll do on our code is use the
from to import from the restaurant module, and we only need to import one
definition, it's the definition of the class restaurant. So, let's try a few
things in the Python interpretor. So, we'll create a new instance of the
restaurant type. And we can see that it has a type. It's type is a class named
Restaurant, that's the type we just defined. Suppose we create another one, so
now have two instances of the restaurant type. They both have the same type, but
are they the same object? If you guessed before I showed you the result. And the
result is False, they're not the same object. They're two different objects.
Another way to see this is to look at their hash. Hash is a built in operator in
Python that maps each object to unique identity. Here, McDowell's has this
fairly minimalist number, you'll get a different number if you try yourself. And
the hash of Chez Bananas is different.